foreign
[Music]
this is Star Talk Cosmic queries Edition
and you know that means I got Chuck Nice
right here hey Chuck hey Neil what's
happening you know who Our Guest is for
Cosmic queries this time uh it's good
old doctor funky spoon David Grimsby
um
what he's uh he's a resident get the
fence out of him get the funk out of my
face he's our at large
astrobiologist and musician and uh a man
who's just all about the solar system
and so we solicited questions from our
fan base that are right in his
wheelhouse and I have maybe five percent
overlap with that wheelhouse so that
means we'll be deferring to David
grinson David welcome back to StarTalk
hey guys thank you it's it's great to be
here great to see you both yeah we count
you as a friend you've been on many many
times and uh your on your resume here
I've got your senior scientist at the
planetary Science Institute and that's
in Arizona is that correct that's in
Arizona I'm in the Washington DC area
through the the magic of uh of the
interwebs uh where PSI planetary
Sciences to sort of distributed we have
people all over the place and uh once a
year we get together in person uh just
like the old days but just to verify
that you're not just Bots yeah exactly
or if we are if we are we're very
sophisticated convincing ones and I'm
reminded you're author of chasing New
Horizons I see what you did there
because there is a mission to Pluto
called New Horizons and as well inside
the Epic first mission to Pluto now
Chuck you see what he did there he's
very uh expectant that there'll be more
missions to Pluto right right but the
way the the subtitle of that New
Horizons was uh screw you Neil
that was uh that was the I see are those
implications
Chuck that's the implied subtitle come
on
actual sometime yeah
but let's not forget about uh my
favorite Dr Funky spoon book If I recall
correctly uh is Earth in human hands
because it's all about how we are
shaping this planet and if you want to
know some great information about
climate change and the anthropocene you
should check out that book man because
it's uh it helped me it's really very
cool wow I didn't know you're now his
agent okay good to know that
Chuck's just my my like Prime audience
if if he likes it then then I know I did
something right so well tell us about
tell us about that book because if
you're if you are a planetary EX expert
then Earth is simply another planet and
then you get to compare it but you know
this it strengths and weaknesses
susceptibilities he does that in a book
actually that's what I meant so I just
want you to let's take me there yeah
well so so I I just thought it would be
I thought it would be cool to uh look at
um sort of the question of you know the
perennial question of what are humans
and what makes us different if anything
it's almost the uh the astrobiologist's
view of you know if you were an alien
with a long attention span watching
Earth and then in this recent stretch of
time you would have seen something
really weird happen to our planet that
has never happened to it before you know
where the night side lights up and the
atmosphere changes and every Everything
Changes and and what does that sort of
look like from a planetary perspective
that was sort of the goal of Earth and
human hands okay cool cool and when was
that published that was published in
2017 2017 and the date on the New
Horizons book that was
um 2018 that was a busy little stretch
for me okay all right I'm still
recovering from all that very cool and
we also have you listed here as a
musician are you active or are you just
sort of play at home where no one's
listening well actually one of the
things that's wonderful for me and I
think for a lot of people about this
stage where the pandemic maybe isn't
over but it's easing up a little bit is
the return of live music and I've been
really enjoying that both as a listener
and fan and also as a performer and I
have been playing I'm I'm in a new band
actually here in the DC area we're
called the easy way and it's kind of a
funk soul
thing and it's uh we've just started
playing we played we've played four gigs
now so that's that's really fun for me
is to be back out playing a little music
and are there any other scientists in
the in the band with you
there are actually uh well no but uh one
one of the other guys that our lead
singer he works at Nasa he's not a
scientist but he's a NASA dude so so we
do NASA does represent so so Chuck you
got questions for us I haven't seen them
yet I don't know if David has uh I'm
sure uh I listen I haven't so okay all
right I don't think anybody has this
this is a cosmic query so tell us what
you got here we go you want to jump into
this let's do it let's uh let's pop
things off with Trevor C Mills Trevor
says hey Dr Tyson Dr grinspoon as well
as Chuck uh I hope this finds you well
this is Trevor from Augusta Georgia at
what point in our search for
extraterrestrial life do we start a
search for non-carbon based life
good candidates
from silicone so okay that's a good
question
you know the thing is I would say
there's not one specific point it's
almost like more a perspective we have
to keep in mind and remember that this
search needs to be conducted with the
the humility of the realization that we
don't really know what we're looking for
we have some hunches about what's
Universal uh about life and we know that
carbon chemistry in water is a basis
that can work and we have uh good reason
to believe that that could be
functioning elsewhere because the
conditions are uh are available for
other places so so it's a good thing to
look for because we we know it can work
and we know we sort of know how to look
for it but
um we should keep in mind that we don't
have any solid reason to believe that
that's the only kind of life we haven't
thought of any other nobody's
constructed or or invented in a lab
another kind of life that works as well
but that just that could be because
we're dumb not because the universe
doesn't know I do it in our movies our
movies we do 100 times over right yeah
it happens in movies and and you know
there is this move in NASA astrobiology
um to look for what we call agnostic bio
signatures which means uh not a trying
to assume as little as possible and
looking for sort of more Universal
things that may not depend on carbon you
know but then you get into this question
what do we even mean by life and what
does life do but you could talk about
um you know chemical disequilibrium
life-changing the chemical balance of
its environment in a way that non-life
probably doesn't and if you go that
route it doesn't have to be carbon based
it just has to be something that's
multiplying itself and and uh using
energy and so so we do have ideas about
how to look for non-carbon based life
and and I think we it's good to be
reminded so so thank you for the
reminder that we should keep keep that
in mind as we search but our search does
tend to be focused on quote Life as we
know it partly because that's what we
know how to look for
so often people will swap try to swap
silicon in for carbon in the molecule
and many satisfy Sci-Fi movies that have
attempted other chemically based life
have done that with silicon and can you
tell me why silicon would be such a
attractive next next option yeah because
in some ways silicon
um is a lot like carbon in that you know
if you look at the periodic table we all
remember the periodic table from the
wall of our our science classroom and
it's got you know in the upper left it's
got high hydrogen and then below
hydrogen are all the things that Bond
like hydrogen with like one electron and
sort of in the middle of that chart is
carbon at the top and then below it are
all the things that Bond like carbon
carbon makes four bonds with other
things and that's the basis of of
organic chemistry which is the basis of
life so you look right below carbon the
next thing down is silicon you think
okay silicon that's going to be kind of
like carbon maybe you can make
biomolecules out of that so there's a
good logic to it but the problem is uh
silicon bonds are not like carbon bonds
what's great about carbon is not just
that it bonds to four other things so it
can make this whole you know
um complex Lego set of of molecules then
it doesn't sound like it it it it it
works it doesn't sound like it it sounds
like it's people making a leap because
it's similarities but that's like me
saying you know
Obama has large ears he's black I could
be president you know no no Chuck no you
can't you cannotize it okay it is kind
of like that it depends on what what
features don't agree with chuck on that
don't I don't know
I'm sorry Neil But Chuck has a point
here
on the show and the fact that the fact
that silicon bonds before the things
makes it like carbon but the problem is
the nature of those bonds carbon bonds
are also kind of floppy and loose and
can you know Carbon can get into all
these like weird configurations which
make proteins and things silicon bonds
tend to be really stiff and you know
they don't make those nice uh complex
configurations the way carbon bonds do
so those who can't see David greenstone
was just Vogue
shaping his hands around his face
chemicals fabricating the flexibility or
rigidity
and strike a silicone
silicon likes to strike a pose stick to
it yeah okay gotcha and and so that's
less flexible when life is experimenting
on the diversity of what it may need to
thrive in an environment
and I don't think it makes like carbon
makes polymers you know these big
molecules where it's not just carbon but
it's attached to lots of other things
silicon it makes you know silicon oxygen
chains and things like that but I don't
think it makes the kind of just diverse
molecule set that makes carbon so good
for life I would add just from an
astrophysical point of view there's like
five times as much carbon in the
universe as there is silicon so you
don't even need to appeal to Silicon
because carbon is there for you and it's
your friend so to both of you with
respect to this
is
are there any conditions in the universe
under which circumstances cause
different reactions to these elements
where they might behave in such a way to
do something like make life or is the
Periodic Chart the same no matter what
no matter where
well the Periodic Chart is going to be
the same uh not for the elements not the
chart I'm talking no but I mean but but
I mean the elements are going to be the
same but your question is good are there
conditions in which the reaction types
the behavior is going to be different
and the answer is yes there are
conditions in which it's different and
that's why we have to be careful to not
be to Earth Centric but has anybody come
up with a set of conditions that we're
likely to find somewhere where you can
show that silicon is going to do the
right thing to make life the answer is
no but that maybe just again be limited
on our imagination
okay is any as any good scientists you
gotta sort of not only know your limits
but be prepared to shatter them as you
as you take every Next Step going
forward right Chuck you got another
question for it all right here yeah yep
yep this is uh Emily
either Talus or talius one or the other
uh because it's a double l so a high
Chuck and Neil greetings from Paris
France so maybe not either one of those
in Productions myself you probably Maybe
not maybe not and then she goes uh oh
look at this Chuck feel free to butcher
my name I can't wait to hear what you
come from
setting you up oh jeez that was good
okay preempt preemptive uh consideration
yeah tell me about it all right she goes
I was wondering what would happen if we
were to discover intelligent life
outside of Earth of course but let's
advance than we are
first how will we discover it and
confirm that it is indeed less
intelligent well that's pretty easy and
second once confirmed what would the
next steps be is there a protocol
for Life Discovery
um yeah first of all I love the question
and it's not one we think about very
much because there's a set of
assumptions
um that are almost unspoken because of
how long we've been assuming them and
how frequently we assume them which
actually David they'll remain unspoken
until we come back from this break yes
they will remain unspoken a little
longer oh just a little longer just a
little longer let's find out about the
unspoken protocol that's the next
installment of Mission Impossible
David's unspoken protocol about
encountering life I will be right back
after this first break
we're back Star Talk
Cosmic queries with David grinspoon a
friend and colleague and he's an expert
on the solar system in astrobiology and
all kinds of cool things such as that uh
David how do we find you on social media
uh well I'm I'm still on Twitter uh at
least today and that's that's
um at Dr funkyspoon
um doctor that's why we call you that Dr
Funky spoon yeah and I'm on um I'm on uh
Facebook just under my name and and uh
I'm on Mastodon now too uh which is I'm
Dr Funk spoon at koto.org q-o-t-o funky
or Funk spoon funky funky funky smooth
okay yeah all right I'm hedging my bets
okay so Chuck we left off with a
question about
from Emily talia's tablet she's from
France was
Emily
yeah uh Emily but so so she wants to
know what happens when we find life
that's less intelligent than it is right
that's hardly ever addressed in a Sci-Fi
storytelling yeah because no one could
imagine that we could be smarter well
it's harder
yeah it's hardly ever dressed in sci-fi
but it's also hardly ever addressed in
um in seti itself because there's always
this assumption that
anybody we find is going to almost
surely be more quote advanced than us or
have been around as a technological
species or civilization much longer and
there's a good Logic for that because
you know on this for one thing on a
cosmic time scale we're just babies
right you know four and a half billion
years of Earth four billion years of
life depending on where you you started
you know a couple million years of being
human and a few hundred years of being
technological and less than 100 years or
100 years of being radio friendly you
know so so we're babies and so that's
one thing just time scale wise but also
anybody who's good at Interstellar
communication or certainly anybody who's
traveling
um in an Interstellar scale is almost
surely uh has technology that we haven't
developed yet you know so there's
there's good logic there so we always
imagine that we are the neophytes and
they're the wise ones and that there's
an asymmetry in contact in that
direction and you know statistically I
think it's a pretty good argument but
it's an interesting question what if we
meet somebody who's uh
you know there's a pretty narrow range
there where they could be dumber than us
and still considered
still considered intelligent but what if
we what if we did and yeah and how would
we find them because presumably then
they wouldn't have traveled here so we'd
have to stumble upon it or responded
right so even even if they're not
traveling here yeah but what if we got
you know what so what if we got lucky it
sort of stumbled on a civilization that
was sort of just becoming technological
but hadn't become Interstellar yet um it
seems like that would just be a tech
level that's not an intelligence level
no that's a good point too because
because you could argue there's you know
there's always the whales right and the
Dolphins they're really intelligent they
arguably have a civilization in it I saw
that Star Trek movie the same whale Star
Trek movie yes yeah yeah so we could
certainly find intelligent life that is
not uh technological at a level we are
um and you know as far as protocols it's
there's it's pretty vague you know there
are protocols for seti if we think we we
found something a radio signal ready to
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
just the general yeah a term for that
right yeah so so this the seti the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
Community has protocols that if somebody
thinks they found a signal then you
don't announce it immediately to the
public first you verify it and you get
another Observatory to also find it so
you make sure it's not some weird
mistake that your Observatory is making
in some local interference but then once
you're sure
um then the the protocol is complete
transparency you alert everybody you
know so uh unless the Men in Black get
to you first yeah that's right with a
flashy thing yeah that
yeah so
um you know and then if if somebody
comes you know and lands a spaceship on
Earth uh and context is we there's no
real official protocol for that because
it's not not something that's just been
uh you know you can argue whether it
should be or shouldn't be but it hasn't
really been taken seriously Enough by
the the sort of seti and scientific
Community to develop a protocol for that
all I know is that in today's world if
the aliens land and they say take us to
your leader nobody's taking them to the
White House
yeah that's so true
it would present a conundrum where do
you take them you take them get a beer
at the Corner Pub
I imagine that my my fantasy is that
they would land and then we find out
that we're so insignificant that they're
actually filming a reality show
oh oh with them Among Us yes exactly
okay like that is that's what we rate as
like hey let's go down there and like
like basically they're the Ashton
Kutcher of the universe and we're the
ones that are being pranked we're pro
we're basically props we're props we're
we're straight up props so David I just
want to add that if we count chimps as
sort of the next smartest species to us
just just for the sake of this for this
example we can't have a meaningful
conversation with him
think about it and we've got 99
identical DNA so if if we find another
species that's sort of not as smart as
us what evidence do we have that we'd be
able to communicate with them or worse
yet finding a species just that one
percent smarter than us than we are to
chimps what hope do we have of them even
being able to communicate with us
because our simplest thoughts would
transcend our most brilliant thinkers
yeah your example of chimps really uh is
an interesting one and it kind of
illustrates that something very recent
has happened uh here on Earth with
humans that uh For Better or Worse where
we have the these qualities of of
language and culture and and so forth
and you know not just I mean chimps you
can argue have a kind of language but
the sort of syntactical language and
ability to express abstract thoughts and
all that maybe you know it's pretty it's
pretty new and it underscores how
unlikely it probably is that we would
connect with somebody else out there who
seemed like an intelligent uh
civilization uh but also was less
um capable than us because you know it
really illustrates that maybe we've just
passed some kind of threshold and on the
other direction yeah so what if somebody
is to us as we are to chimps that may be
possible but it may also be that this
sort of threshold is something that one
once you're over it then maybe you sort
of can communicate even if you recognize
that these guys are geniuses compared to
us
that's David's human ego
yeah we we hate that thresholder we
could communicate with any intelligent
species smarter than us right you keep
thinking that David I said maybe
or maybe not maybe maybe we're dumb as
rocks compared to just about everybody
in the universe I like that one that's
mine that's the one there you go Chuck
keep them coming all right this is
Sandra baliani Sandra bayani says good
morning or evening wonderful Star Talk
hosts and listeners this one came to me
as I was flying to Seattle and looking
out the window love it love looking out
the window yeah why are black holes
generally situated in the center of
galaxies why that specific area and yes
this is the kind of stuff that I think
about while I'm on planes looking out
the window
that's good because a whole lot of stuff
you can think of to create anxiety and
things yeah if you can think about black
holes on a plane and not feel anxious
that's that's good so David I should
probably take this one right yeah I was
going to say that uh we we actually have
an astrophysicist here and it's not me
uh so a black hole our understanding of
black holes tells us that you can get it
from the death of a very high mass star
the sun is not among them and high mass
stars are very rare so these would be
stars that are dotted around the Galaxy
from a black holes that is the remnant
of a supermassive star that lived out
its life and died and in the final
collapse it collapsed all the way over
black hole we expect those black holes
to be pretty much rare but everywhere if
if you can imagine if you can picture
that so so in other words wherever you
had Stars being born you'd have like
maybe one of these all right so there
are fewer of them than all the total
Stars by far but there's no part of the
Galaxy that would be without them so
that's for start so that's a one kind
those are called uh Stellar black holes
then just empirically we discovered that
the centers of galaxies
have black holes in them we just it was
a discovery in my life while I was in
graduate school this discovery took root
and we say well we've got one in our
galaxy and one in a nearby Galaxy and
then well there's another galaxy over
here we we can get data and we show a
black hole and so we extrapolated we
said if it's in these three galaxies it
must be in all galaxies because it's
hard enough to get those data and those
galaxies were very different from each
other so then we just went on the
assumption that every big Galaxy would
have a supermassive black hole and sure
enough Hubble Telescope gets launched
and every Galaxy we look into and have
the quality of data to know they've all
got a supermassive black hole and we do
not yet know how they were formed and
the James Webb Space Telescope is
exquisitely tuned to see the birth of
galaxies and from those data we might be
able to see material collecting in the
middle to form the supermassive black
holes that dot the center of every
Galaxy and again a sense of it a black
hole
Stellar black hole might be five ten
times the mass of the Sun but the
supermass of black holes in the centers
of galaxies is hundreds of thousands up
to millions of times the mass of the Sun
so if it's consistent that it's the
death of a star that makes that
do we see stars that have that mass in
the universe that might be able to
create the supermassive black hole that
coalesces a Galaxy no no okay yeah it
starts to give out at about 60 to 100
times the mass of the sun we don't find
Stars more heavier than that so we're
not going to find a billion times mass
of the sun star right just have never
seen that and so that's what we think
something else is making them that's it
has something else yep that's that's
that is wow that is a wonderful mystery
yeah yeah well the universe Grims with
Mysteries that's why David and I have a
job I
I love the fact that for the
supermassive black hole it in our own
Galaxy we can actually watch the Stars
orbiting it so and in a Nobel prize
winning observations uh yes we can
you're watching these stars do these
loops and loops and there's nothing
there in the middle nothing right it's
enough to make you really believe
and you run the math on the orbits and
the speeds and and the distances and you
get a black hole you get a black circle
yes it's not cool it's not a NASCAR
track it's a black hole that's very cool
all right here we go
um
this is his name is on another page
Gavin mallow and Gavin says greetings
from Beaver Creek hello David Neil and
Chuck and that's Beaver Creek Ohio I
forgot the Ohio part okay I'm curious
about the possibility of Life on an
Earth-like planet that would lack the
protective sleeve that Earth's
atmosphere and magnetic fields Supply us
What would life do to accommodate these
relative extreme conditions could
anything on Earth potentially be
transmissible to an environment as such
I like that yeah David we got these we
got these protect you know our
atmosphere protects us from meteors it
protects us from UV light it's you know
so we're here
uh by the grace of the atmosphere and so
if there's a planet out there earth size
Earth gravity Goldilocks zone maybe and
doesn't have these protecting forces
what what do we do
yeah that's that's a great question I'm
I'm less worried about the magnetic
field part which is the other thing that
the questioner asks because we're
learning more that makes us wonder how
important magnetic fields are in
protecting the surface of a planet uh we
used to say that without that it was the
lack of a magnetic field that made Mars
lose its atmosphere for instance but
more recent observations have made us
question that and the role of a magnetic
field in protecting the atmosphere
itself is not so clear and then there's
the example of of one of my favorite
planets of Venus which has no intrinsic
magnetic field but because it has a
thick atmosphere it's still protected in
fact Venus develops what's called an
induced magnetic field where just the
the solar wind itself sort of makes the
upper atmosphere charged in such a way
that it starts acting like it has a
magnetic field and David if memory
serves you wrote a book on Venus too
this is correct yes sorry you wrote a
book on Earth about Venus that's right I
was out on Venus when I wrote the book
but I wrote a book on the subject of
Venus at the time so that book was what
that's that's Venus revealed revealed
there you go okay yeah so you've been at
this for a while very yeah yeah so so
magnetic fields I think life could life
would find a way but um but an
atmosphere fills so many roles not only
does it protect from dangerous radiation
ultraviolet light and cosmic rays but of
course it also
um serves to transport
um you know think of Earth and the the
role of oxygen and carbon dioxide and
plants and animal life the transporting
of
um chemicals that are involved in in the
metabolism of organisms of you know
trading energy between molecules and so
forth It's hard to imagine life evolving
on the surface of a planet without an
atmosphere now of course there are
places in the solar system without
atmospheres where we think there might
be life on on the inside like say Europa
and so one could imagine an Earth-like
planet without an atmosphere that still
had the chemical stuff happening and the
and the and the energy transformations
on the inside so that maybe you'd have
internal life
um in in the interior of the planet but
but it but an atmosphere is so integral
to the kind of life that we have on
Earth that it really sort of stretches
the imagination to to think of how you
would get a biosphere without an
atmosphere and and and there's nothing
wrong with stretching the imagination I
mean this is true that's why we like
these kinds of questions yeah yeah yeah
Chuck we got to take a quick break okay
David we'll be back in just a moment for
our third and final segment with David
grinspoon on Star Talk
we're back Star Talk Cosmic queries all
about the solar system and searching for
life and astrobiology with one of the
world's leading experts on these very
subjects David grinspoon a friend and
colleague at the planetary Science
Institute itself based in Arizona but he
is distributed uh he's part of the PSI
at large community based in Washington
D.C always good to have you David you're
a friend of our show and thanks for
responding to our always great to be
here with you guys yeah let's make this
kind of like a lightning round all right
and we'll speed it up as we go along
because we only got through like five
questions and we got more tons of them
let's keep going
all right here we go Eric shurikan or
sharakan says uh Hey from Boston what
does Dr David grinspoon think about the
James Webb Space telescope's recent
exoplanet Discovery particularly that it
appears similar to Earth in size and in
composition yeah David you know when we
designed the damn telescope it was to
look for Galaxies at the edge of the
universe and then you planet people are
starting to use it to like look at stuff
right in front of our noses so who when
what in the dark of what night did that
when did that happen yeah all right well
first of all Boston my hometown yay go
Celtics and um the uh it's it's
wonderful what I think of that is you
know like uh as Neil implies the the the
web was not designed to uh look at
exophantis it was designed for uh
galaxies and other things like that
astrophysical targets but
um you know I chalk it up to the fact
that the universe is just so incredibly
productive when it comes to planets much
more than we thought even when people
started designing the web and so it in a
way it's luck you know there turns out
Webb is sort of marginal for exoplanets
but there's so many good targets that
we're starting to find them and they the
exciting prospect now is that we can
start to see what their atmospheres are
made of even though again web is not the
ideal instrument for that and we've got
other ones of course we want to build in
the future that will be more more ideal
we're we're going to learn some really
cool and important things about our our
planets in uh in nearby star systems and
that's pretty opportunistic and that
that's good absolutely good time
absolutely all right keep it coming all
right let's just keep going succinct
answer David okay look through this
third round okay go keep it a move and
Kyle Marston says hey yo hey yo hey
I didn't say that he did uh how many
Earth-like planets do we know about
currently that reside in habitable
orbits
is there a number
uh you know there's there's a lot of
marginal ones uh I would say
um I would say a handful you know
um which is which is pretty good because
when you come when it comes to saying
habitable orbits some of them were sort
of guessing because it really depends on
whether they have an atmosphere or not
and what the details of their climates
but there's a you know there's a good a
dozen or so that um seem like pretty
good with candidates they're 5 000
planets in the catalog right now and you
tell me there's only like a dozen that
are Goldilocks Planet I'm saying ones
that we and it depends what you mean by
Earth-like okay these are these are all
gray areas but I'm saying I'm saying
roughly earth-sized and definitely uh
good candidates to be in the habitable
zone and maybe have liquid oceans and
things like that it's a small but
growing number okay all right so that
would be if we did it in percentages it
what's 10 out of 5 000 so what is that
it's one out of 500. so that's still
pretty low that's like a fifth of one
percent
right yeah but you know but a lot of
those 5 000 are ones that that will
could be these are I I I'm giving a
conservative number for ones that we can
say yes that's earth-sized and yes that
is so there's really in the running in
the running yeah absolutely but it's
still big news it's still big news when
we find one yeah that's why it's so
exciting that you know it's this one
that was just mentioned because like oh
yeah that's earth-sized and it seems to
be in the habitable zone that's it's
still news yes yes which is a good thing
it means people are so excited and there
aren't enough for them to get bored with
it yet okay
Chuck keep it coming all righty here we
go this is
I I think I mean you you maybe you're
the reader here so yeah it's always what
you think okay you're right exactly yeah
I'm gonna tell you the truth I really
don't think that but that's about as
close as I can come okay uh he says hey
Neil hey David and Seth MacFarlane's the
Orville 25th Century life has progressed
far into the Galaxy solve societal
health and technological issues and
eliminated money as a form of currency
do you think this future is viable and
what steps do present-day humans need to
take individually as well as on a larger
scale to walk towards that goal how can
we push for science literacy globally
wow okay so David answer that in three
sentences if you can uh I I would say in
three senses yes I think it's possible
though not assured
um and that the path is not going to be
smooth between here and there and that
the the key is some sort of a globally
enlightened Society where we uh guide
ourselves with the recognition that we
are one planetary species uh despite all
of our wonderful differences so it's a
guidance Force operating on our future
decisions
yeah right well there you go here's your
answer we're screwed
okay and I think just just to remind
people I think the original Star Trek
after which so much of the Orville is so
much of it is inspired forces operating
within the storytelling of Orville if I
remember correctly the reason why
there's no money is because they they
someone developed a replicator where you
if you need another one of something
just make another one in it so you
didn't have to go out and buy it or earn
money to obtain it so it's post post
scarcity correct a post-scarcity world
right where anything could just come out
of a box a machine that you you create
and so that changes what people care
about what they value and all the right
but one of them is you don't need money
it's interesting because money is just a
belief system anyways we all fool
ourselves into thinking again it has
value so it does have value right so we
could always change our minds
collectively about that right right yeah
and the other thing too is once they got
rid of money they people started to do
what they wanted to do which so you
naturally end up with a passion for life
because everybody's doing what they want
to do rather than what they have to do
in order to pay the rent exactly wow
okay but then how do you explain
ferengi's well yeah they're greedy
little bastards
pretty little
bear they have it all and they still
want more you know but Chuck what you
said is deep because it it what it would
do it would Liberate the creativity of
every citizen of the world right yeah
who contribute in whatever way best
floats their boat and they'll probably
be better at that than anything else
they would have done right because
they'll do it because they want because
yeah yeah exactly they have to indeed I
like it I like it I think I think we
should just like start that world right
now
oh that's great
and on January 17th
a revolution took hold
fire across the face of the globe
all right so this is Cameron Bellamy who
says greetings from Baltimore Maryland
what aspects of a planet's climate are
planetary scientists looking for when
evaluating planets for potential to
support life additionally how close to
these planets need to be to Earth to
look for these aspects in the planet's
climate I like that yeah yeah so that's
it's it's a good question so I mean the
basic factor that we're always very
focused on is a climate in the range
where water would be predominantly
liquid and again that could just be our
own bias because you know as we talked
about it earlier maybe we're not smart
enough to think of other kinds of life
that don't need water but Earth so much
of what makes Earth the way it is is
because the climate balance is such that
we live on a water planet and that is in
every cell of your body is liquid water
interacting with organic molecules so so
that's the number one thing there's
enough greenhouse gases
um the good carbon dioxide yeah exactly
the a good amount of greenhouse gases
carbon dioxide water a little methane
sulfur dioxide these are the gases that
absorb infrared radiation and make a
planet warm but not so much that you
have a Venus that's just too hot for
liquid water so that that's the sort of
prime directive if you will for for
habitability
um and what was the second part of the
question
um what do we look for
um to to um oh how far away how far away
yeah yeah
um again you know with the tools we have
now we can there's it's it's very
difficult to
um tell what's in a planet's atmosphere
unless it's not just distance the
geometry has to be right if we have what
we call a transiting Planet so it passes
in its orbit right between us and its
star then you can look at the radiation
coming from that star as it passes
through the atmosphere and see how it's
filtered out and what molecules are
there but it's easier to do that if
you're you know within a few hundred
light years than if you're thousands of
light years but crap but if we as we get
better instruments
um that we want to build in the future
we'll be able to greatly expand the
number of planets we can do that for now
just a quick addition here I remember
watching Star Trek and just you ever
noticed David Chuck they never wore
spacesuits when they went down to Planet
surfaces right have you ever thought
about that
[Laughter]
at some point the Spock would say uh
it's a oxygen nitrogen atmosphere
Captain right
and but I would hear that and it was as
though all we have to do is find an
oxygen nitrogen planet to move to and
then I realized and David correctly if
I'm wrong here
if it has oxygen something's making the
oxygen so so you are already looking for
planets that had some kind of life forms
on it to create that atmosphere in the
first place it's not that there's all
kinds of random atmospheres that exist
on all the planets and pick the ones
that you happen to be able to breathe
this this active stuff going on there is
that fair yeah the reason why the reason
why we have a breathable atmosphere is
because there's life here right oh wow
and so any Planet you find with that
kind of atmosphere would be very
surprising uh like like you say Neil
what what else would be making an
atmosphere with just that mixture it's
hard to imagine that it's not brimming
with life right right right so cool okay
a couple more Chuck man we're blowing
through these very nice right yes we are
yes we are here we are uh this is right
now we're we're we got to speed up even
more so David sound bite mode okay
remember all right so ABC News just put
a microphone in front of your lips and
they're going to sound bite you for the
evening news so here it is
all right uh hello Chuck hello Neil
hello Dr Funky spoon
um
okay here we go
does weed still work in space or the THC
crystals too fragile for space what
temperature uh what hemp crop would be
great best to grow on Mars
I'll say I don't know that the
experiment's ever been tried but in all
seriousness one thing I wonder about
NASA never took weed into the space
station
not that I know of but I will say in all
seriousness one of the big problems with
astronaut health is eye pressure ocular
pressure and one of the things that is
well established that cannabis does
medically is good for glaucoma because
it reduces ocular pressure so I've
always thought and I've kind of
whispered this to a few people at Nasa
but like why don't you try that
right on okay yeah yeah and you don't
you don't have to you don't have to
smoke it we have gummies
about the soils of Mars can you grow
anything there
yeah I mean if you could grow uh
anything I mean the thing you know
cannabis is just another plant so if you
grow tomatoes you're going to be able to
grow cannabis there it's okay so
whatever the soil the soil by itself as
of now probably isn't very uh isn't very
fertile you know because it doesn't it
doesn't have Organics from the book and
movie The Martian yeah but it could
certainly you could certainly mix in a
mix in a little uh either human
generated or otherwise generated
fertilizer and grow stuff on Mars
human generated fertilizer fertilizer
yeah
not the problem we call that hgf
nice nice one last one Chuck this one
here we go this is uh
akshat
oh man it actually take you as long to
read the name as the question itself
because I don't prepare
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
uh uh patrika that's it
who says this
hey hello and greetings from India I was
wondering whether Venus was once a
habitable planet and their civilization
was there uh living on the planet but
unfortunately they destroyed themselves
due to extreme climate change
what yeah history have to
the evolution of the entire planet
thanks and I love the show
it's from India
yeah yes growing their presence in space
with satellites and space missions and
things yeah and they have a Venus
Mission that's announced an Indian Venus
mission where that came from they're
very good okay but um so so company of
space-faring Nations short answer
yes indeed a short answer I've often
wondered that myself but it's true that
we think that Venus probably was
habitable although that's one of the
motivations for our upcoming missions is
to determine was it really we think it
had oceans in Boston but we wanted
gather the evidence to be sure of that
um we generally don't talk about an
ancient civilization on Venus although
one has to admit that we have not
explored the planet well enough to rule
that out
okay where what you said you don't talk
about it that implies you don't talk
about it in public or something no no no
I said that Chuck yeah we don't talk
about it we don't I just mean that's
that's not a monster in the Disney movie
we don't talk about Bruno but yeah I
meant that's not amongst our most
favored hypotheses but it's certainly
not that thing we can rule out
thanks for letting me clarify that yes
thank you very very much there but
clearly Venus does have a runaway
greenhouse effect and they're just
worried maybe the the Venus has knobs
that got turned right that had it become
what it is and we should look at those
very same knobs here on Earth yeah no I
mean a serious answer is that by
studying what happened to Venus we can
be better prepared to understand changes
in Earth's future and that indeed is one
of the big motivations for understanding
what happened to The Climate there now
is that is is is runaway greenhouse
effect some something that can happen
under the conditions that we have like
our planet could undergo the same thing
could that happen I'm just saying like
not not that we make that that it is
going to happen but is it possible here
that people have people have looked at
this and the answer is if you burned all
the fossil fuels on Earth of course you
would make things awful and
uninhabitable for humans but you
probably would not trigger a Venus style
runaway greenhouse effect where all the
oceans boiled off but but in the future
as the sun warms up which it is slowly
in you know a billion years or so
um then there probably will be a runaway
greenhouse effect on earth like there
was on Venus in the past so if we wait
long enough then the sun will help us do
that so you hear that Chuck when an
astrophysicist says in the future his
next phrase was a billion years
always yes there's some serious ass
future that we're talking about exactly
yeah we have more immediate problems but
none of unless it's still interesting
too much
get David's blessing on this comment
before we close it out so David in all
my readings on this I I agree that if
you extracted all fossil fuels and
burned them all with none left the Earth
would be hotter but you would not have
the runaway greenhouse effect
experienced by Venus what you would need
to do
is
um somehow dissolve all of the world's
Limestone and other repositories of
carbon that's beyond just fossil fuels
or fossils right and and if you put all
of that carbon added to the carbon that
the fossil fuel burning would then we
could become a twin of Venus in that way
is that is that fair yeah I think that's
right because then I mean Venus has sort
of uh like a hundred hundred bars almost
of CO2 which is 100 times the
atmospheric thickness of Earth if you
burn all the fossil fuels you're not
going to get that much carbon in Earth's
atmosphere but yeah if you dissolve all
the Limestone and sort of took all the
carbon in Earth's crust and somehow put
it in the atmosphere I don't think
anybody should should try this yeah
don't try this at home then then I think
you probably could turn Earth into Venus
yeah okay all right so we're not doing
that for sure but but the one thing we
know for certain
is that greenhouse effect is from carbon
in the atmosphere that is just the way
oxide carbon dioxide so carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere done deal Greenhouse
Effect and we know that we are doing
that through burning fossil fuels here
right now right absolutely absolutely
we're going in that direction and it's
the wrong direction for us okay there
you go for our survival all right all
right we got to call it quits there on
that down I was going to say I had a
truck I had a good news good night a
couple of minutes ago and then you have
to just take it down
a few minutes ago we were abolishing all
money and like liberating human
creativity
in the last
those are the breaks this is start talk
Cosmic queries one of our favorite
variants on the Stark talk franchise
Neil deGrasse Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist I want to thank David for
coming back to StarTalk he's a friend of
the show and of course Chuck Nice always
good to have you there always a pleasure
as always
all right